PROFESSOR: We spoke last
time of the existence
of symmetric states.
And for that we were
referring to states
psi S that belonged to the
M particle Hilbert space.
And V is the vector space that
applies to the states of the M
particles.
And we constructed some states.
So within the construction,
we postulated,
there will be some
states that [AUDIO OUT]
that meant that any permutation
of [AUDIO OUT] state
will be for the symmetric
state or all alpha.
So that meant the
state was symmetric.
Whatever you apply to
it, any permutation,
the state would be invariant.
So these are special states,
if they exist, in VN.
Then there would be
anti-symmetric states.
And we concluded that an
anti-symmetric state--
with an A for anti-symmetric--
also stayed in this
tensor product.
That state would
react differently
to the permutation operators.
It would change up to a
sine epsilon alpha times
psi A. It would be an eigen
state of all those permutation
operators.
But with eigenvalue
epsilon and alpha
where epsilon alpha
was equal to plus
1 if P alpha is an
even permutation.
Or minus 1 if P alpha
is an odd permutation.
So whether this
permutation is even or odd,
we also discussed
depends on whether it's
built with an even or odd
number of transpositions.
With transpositions being
permutations in which
one state is flipped
for another state.
Within the end
states, you pick two,
and these two are flipped,
that's a transposition.
All permutations can be built
through transpositions--
with transpositions--
and therefore you
can tell from a
permutation whether it's
an even or an odd one
depending of whether it's
built with even number of
transpositions or odd number
of transpositions.
Now, the number
of transpositions
you need to build the
permutation is not fixed.
If we say it's even,
means it's even mod 2.
So you might have a permutation
is built with 2 transpositions.
And also somebody
else can write it
as 4 transpositions
and 6 transpositions.
It just doesn't matter.
So a few facts that we
learned about these things
are that all the P alphas
are unitary operators.
And we also learned
that all transpositions
are Hermitian operators.
Now, transpositions, of
course, are permutations.
So they're Hermitian, and
they're unitary as well.
And finally, we learned that
the number of even permutations
is equal to the number of odd
permutations in any permutation
group of n objects.
So these were some of the facts
we learned last time already.
We have now that symmetric
states form a subspace.
If you have two
symmetric states,
you can multiply a
state by a number,
it will still be symmetric.
If you add two symmetric
states, will still be symmetric.
So symmetric states form a
subspace of the full vector
space V tensor N.
And anti-symmetric
states also form
a subspace of the vector
space, V tensor N.
So let's write these facts.
So symmetric states
form the subspace,
and it's called sym N of V
of V tensor N. Anti-symmetric
states form the subspace
anti N V of V tensor N.
All right.
So these are the states.
But we have not learned how to
build them, how to find them,
and even more, what
to do with them.
So main thing is if
this form subspaces,
there should be a way to
write the projector that
takes from your big space
down to the subspace.
So here is the
claim that we have.
Here are two operators.
We'll call this S,
a symmetrizer And S
will be billed as 1 over N
factorial, the sum over alpha
of all the
permutations, P alpha.
That's the definition.
And then we'll have an
anti-symmetrizer, A. This is
also 1 over N factorial,
sum over alpha.
Epsilon alpha P alpha.
Where epsilon alpha,
again, is that sine factor
for each permutation.
So here are two
operators, and we're
going to try to prove
that these operators are
orthogonal projectors
that take you
to the subspace's
symmetric states
and anti-symmetric states.
So that is our first goal.
Understanding that these
operators do the job.
And then we'll see what
we can do with them.
So there are several
things that we
have to understand
about these operators.
If they are projectors, they
should square to themselves.
So S times S should be
equal to S. Remember, that's
the main equation
of a projector.
A projector is P
squared equals P.
And the second thing,
they should be Hermitian.
So let's try each of them.
So the first claim is that
S and A are Hermitian.
In particular, S dagger equal
S. And A dagger equal A.
So if you want to prove
something like that,
it's not completely
obvious at first sight
that those statements are true.
Because we saw, for
example, that transpositions
are Hermitian operators.
But the general permutation
operator is not Hermitian.
It's unitary.
So it's not so obvious.
You cannot just say each
operator is Hermitian,
and it just works out.
It's a little more
complicated than that.
But it's not extremely
more complicated than that.
So let's think of the
following statement.
I claim that if you have the
list of all the permutation
operators.
Put the list in front of you.
All of them.
And you apply Hermitian
conjugation to that whole list,
you get another
list of operators.
And it will be just the
same list scrambled.
But you will get the same list.
It will contain all of them.
And that is kind of obvious
if you think about it a little
more.
You have here, for example, the
list of all the permutations.
And here, you apply Hermitian
conjugation, HC or dagger.
And you get another list.
And this list is the same as
this one although reordered.
In a sense, it permutes
the permutation operators,
if you wish.
And the reason is clear.
If you have two operators
here, and you apply--
they are different-- and you
apply Hermitian conjugation,
it should give two
different operators here.
Because if they were equal,
you could apply again
Hermitian operator conjugation.
And you would say,
oh, they're equal.
But you assume they
were different.
So two different operators go
to two different operators here.
Moreover, any operator here--
you can call it O--
is really equal to O dagger.
O dagger.
Hermitian conjugation
twice gives you back.
So any operator here is
the Hermitian conjugation.
Hermitian conjugate of
some operator there.
So every operator
here will end up
at the end of an
arrow coming here.
Maybe those arrows,
we could put them
like they go in all directions.
But the fact is
that when you take
Hermitian conjugation
of all the list,
you get all the list back.
Therefore, that takes
care of the symmetrizer.
When I take the Hermitian
conjugation of P alpha,
I might get another P beta.
But at the end of the
day, the whole sum
will become again the whole sum.
So that proves the fact
that this map is 1 to 1
The map Hermitian
conjugation is 1 to 1.
1 and surjective meaning
that every element
is reached as well.
Means that S dagger
is equal to S.
Because the list doesn't change.
Here is a slightly
more subtle point.
This time, the list
is going to change.
But then maybe when this
changes to another operator,
maybe the epsilon is
not the right epsilon.
You would have to
worry about that.
But that's no worry either.
That also works out clearly.
Because of the following thing.
If a permutation
P alpha is even,
it's billed with an even
number of transpositions.
If you take the
Hermitian conjugation
of an even number
of transpositions,
you'll get an even
number of transpositions
in the other order.
That's what Hermitian
conjugation is.
Therefore, Hermitian conjugation
doesn't change the fact
that the permutation
is even or is odd.
So if P alpha has a sine
factor E of P alpha.
Let's write it more explicitly.
And P alpha dagger has as a
sine factor E of P alpha dagger.
These two are the same.
If P alpha is even, P
alpha dagger is even.
If P alpha is odd,
P alpha is odd.
Therefore, when you take
the Hermitian conjugate
of this thing, you may map.
You think the Hermitian
conjugate of this sum.
You have here a dagger would
be 1 over N factorial, sum
over alpha, epsilon alpha,
P alpha dagger, which
is another permutation.
But this permutation.
For this permutation,
this sine factor
is the correct sine factor.
Because the sine
factor for P alpha
dagger is the same as the
sine factor of E alpha.
Since we get the whole sum
by the statement before,
A is also Hermitian.
So OK.
Not completely obvious,
but that's a fact.
If you think more
abstractly, this
is something you
could know on a group.
If you have a group that
has all kinds of elements.
Many of you have written papers
in groups in your essays.
Then if you take
every group element,
and you replace
it by its inverse,
you get the same list
of group elements.
It's just scrambled.
And remember, since this
permutations are unitary,
taking Hermitian conjugation
is the same thing
as taking an inverse.
So when you take
a group, and you
take the inverse
of every element,
you get back the list of
the elements of the group.
And that's what's
happening here.